bonjour et bienvenue dans cette vidéo de
tubes cold reading numéro deux c'est
comme le volume 1 mais c'est pas tout à
fait pareil
alors pourquoi parce que j'avais envie
de faire une suite mais je me suis dit
que c'est toujours un petit peu la même
chose tu vois alors j'ai demandé à mon
pote pierre bock 2 organisé ça avec
fanny comme la première fois mais en
plus de me trouver un défi à réaliser
quelque chose qui change un petit peu de
l'ordinaire
je vais découvrir ça avec vous sachez
aussi que j'ai un décalage horaire dans
les dents de six heures et du coup si
vous me voyez un petit peu décroché
c'est normal pierre bock
c'est à vous alors du coup fait l'un tu
m'a demandé d'organiser cette super
vidéo call reading 2 et je te propose en
fait la même chose que la dernière fois
d'où te vient ses doigts de vivre
concrètement donnant de notes
du coup tu vas devoir deviner des choses
sur les gens à savoir par exemple le
rôle je leur métier et c'est une autre
fois comme deux fois je vois tu verras
un petit point au tactile 6 alors j'ai
une fascination pour les bons points
j'aime les bons points je suis fan des
bons points si tu en a au moins une
quinzaine
oui sachant qu'il ya six invités il ya
six invités en tout inquiète citant
collecte d'une quinzaine que le rock et
oméga défi ok je peux pas te dire tout
de suite ce que c'est et je vais en
collecter combien par invité 5à donc il
faut que j'envoie quand justement à fond
mais ça n'a pas de sens c'est quoi la
mégane qui je ne te le dis pas par
contre tu as un super truc à gagner
c'est vrai un truc que tu adores
inquiète
ok j'ai kiffé bon courage à mes attentes
je t'ai like toi en tant de vidéos et je
m'abonne à toi j'ai pas tout
[Musique]
bonjour donc se peut qu'on mère enfermée
dans les toilettes
d'autant que tout le monde arrive aussi
un jour vous devez être enfermé dans les
toilettes prenez votre téléphone puisque
vraiment à toilettes ans feuillage en
fait ok j'arrive sa ses portes tire la
langue
bonjour besoins des 30 ans des manèges
fabien chanter emmanuel merci et benoît
d'accord voilà vous n'étiez pas censés
venir les prénoms mais comme ça ça
m'aide
il faut que tu essayes de deviner qu'ils
aiment dans la vie leur métier lord a
donné sens il reste trop ça marche si
toi aussi tu le sens mieux s'ils ont des
animaux d'accord si oui lesquels
[Musique]
donc tu m'as dit en prenant ces deux
noix le pays où le taureau le bélier
octobre et du hockey est manuel va être
plus dur pour toi ok moral de vainqueur
compétiteurs gagnant je m'intéresse à
toi parce qu'en fait tu as des signes
contradictoires par exemple au niveau
bon si on parle de l'état de tes
chaussures et des chaussures par rapport
à ton style mais en même temps par
rapport à ta carrure et puis en même
temps par rapport à l'état de témoins
qui sont plutôt cool et comment tu te
soignes etc de cheveux en fait il ya
plein de choses qui se contredisent
je pense que je sais que tu es quelqu'un
de très bien dans ton époque je pense
donc que tu travailles dans des choses
actuelles moderne informatique et il
peut à rien lâcher revenant sur benoît
qui était beaucoup plus expressifs alors
qu'il ne le voulait pas juste choco que
c'était bon sur le cinéaste rend du coup
tu peux lui donner un plan hockey
culture merci beaucoup
alors comme ça tu me disais que tu
faisais beaucoup de sport si c'était les
jambes qu'il me disait et puis comme ça
quand tu te penches et j'ai pu aussi
voir un petit peu les épaules parce que
attention c'est un mec qui est hyper fit
natation oui natation ça c'est tous les
profils a fini comme ça mais le nul
vierge mais qui coule la datation pour
la natation natation 1 point en fait par
rapport à ta position comment tu te
tiens et après je sais pas si vous avez
vu les vidéos que j'ai fait sur les
préjugés
je fonctionne aussi sur les préjugés je
te lis un petit peu à la compétition via
le sport et du coup je te lis toi aussi
je te lis un peu la compétition mais
plus pour le mental méthode plus sur le
sport et du coup je me dis que tu dois
aimer
enfin tut tut doit pas aimer quand c'est
pas juste tu dois aimer les trucs les
résultats en fait comment quantifier on
dit ça c'est comme ça par contre j'ai
pas dit grand chose sur toi quand même
bref informatique c'était pas bon si ces
bons à six et vous intéresse cool je me
pense que tu as un animal j'en retiens
au chat et toi je leur ai dit que
t'avais pas d'animaux par rapport à tout
ce que j'ai vu là oui ça marche un bon
point pour les animaux dit si j'ai
d'autres choses je les dirai plus tard
l'animal
non non il faut aller plus loin quand
même
j'étais d'accord avec ma maman m'a
n'annoncer l'émir bon journée j'en ai
six quand même ses placements
par contre pierre idrac son slip il
vient de me dire maintenant tu devines
leurs dernières vacances
en fait c'est du coaching c'est pas de
la voyance donc plus forte que nico tu
vois tu je ne sais pas il ya six ans un
indice ostentatoire sur eux
bonjour fait rien enchanté c'est à lui
et l'isae et marie curie mac
[Musique]
ok d'accord merci beaucoup tu dessines
oui ok j'ai des bons plans en fait
j'aime beaucoup cette version du colza
dit d'accord ok on n'est pas du tout sur
le même métier je pense jobs créatif
artistique sûrement en rapport avec le
dessin d'ailleurs très coloré
contrastées pas illustratrice graphiste
quelque chose comme ça c'est quoi c'est
ça il est tout à fait partie mary mary
mary mary mary mary créative aussi par
contre je
tous les stéréotypes s'écoule tablier
comme dans la vie tous les jours ok ça
marche technicienne régisseuse
régisseuse hockey son lumière je vis est
ce qu'on peut partir sur l'âge de
naissance au genre de choses âge date de
naissance heure h 26 pour toi c'est pas
mal mais maintenant ça vaut pas un point
je t'ai vue d'accords la tension est un
peu plus jeune
cinq ans - va ben 21,21 points soit 1
point
ok ça marche si gastro intéressant quand
je sais déjà
depuis que je suis rentré en tout cas
j'ai mon préjugé qui est le signe sur
lequel a encore une fois je crois pas à
la voyance 1 mais j'aimais stéréotypes
tac et celui pour lequel c'est plus
facile pour moi c'est lyon et jeu direct
et llano oui ça marche je vais couper la
poire en deux mais si j'ai une bombe
donne pas de bons points je dirais
sagittaire mais non c'est enfin je veux
rien c'est parce que c'est scorpions
séducteur ou capricorne et j'ai dit je
comprendre ça méritait bien tu leur as
martin n'a pas d'animaux chez toi c'est
avant tout pour moi il ya une chimie
chat tu vois si non juste un chien
mestach laquelle on pas les chiens j'ai
la peau du dj la phobie des chiens taf
et chaque il dépose pas deux fois le nul
part merci mais je passe mon temps à la
va vite un toit pour les animaux je ne
sais pas du tout je ne me couche
directeur n'a pas jugé bon pour les
garçons mais si t'as pas des plus moyens
nouveaux pour marier on peut dire
manière assez su alors on peut dire que
ça colle à tout le monde mais pas tant
que ça l'importante sur la loyauté sur
le respect sur la justice sur toutes ces
choses là en fait toutes les notions du
bien vivre ensemble mais en mode un peu
trash parking qui peut s'énerver si
c'est pas respecté je m'énerve jamais
mais j'essaye kamerhe mais sinon oui
mais pour moi c'est quelque chose qui
marche plus sur elle que sur toi par
exemple tu vois
alors que je partage penser pareil que
les bases et les valeurs qui marche à
tout le monde d y en a qui sont
sensibles comme je pense que tu être
créative
je pense que tu aimes là en général
musique dessin etc
évidemment je pense une sensibilité sur
tout ce qui est culture culture
japonaise manga cosplay et tout ça et du
coup vis-à-vis de ça je pense que ce que
tu n'aimes pas sont des choses usi
rationnelle plus plus globale que dès
que toi tu es plus terre-à-terre en fait
dans ce que tu aimes us que tu m'aimes
pas je pense que toi c'est plus ce genre
peur du noir ou des choses comme ça je
dis pas que ta peur du noir mais tu vois
ce que veut dire je pense que c'est des
choses global oui ça marche seront donc
être cool pour les deux répond je te
donne un point merci pierre bock
merci bonjour ça lui va bien
on chante et on te dis merci anthony ap
c'est bon bonjour l allemagne c est par
ces mots
[Musique]
ok cool merci ok merci
d'accord je sais déjà plein de choses
sur harmony et anthony pas beau pour
l'instant j'ai aucune idée du métier
n'implique donc peut commencer par l'âge
l'âge
oui bien sûr l'âge de 26 ans comme ça
dans 26 ans 26 c'est un bon point
tournage 24-25 plus oui beaucoup plus
28-28 ok mais ça arrive souvent non
qu'on sache pas te donner ta joue pas
enfin je reviens des états unis les
banques l'anacarde identité tout le
temps au casino mes enfants j'ai jamais
produit en vrai à des traits de ton âge
en même temps tu as physique global est
une qualité de peau on se dit bin tun en
fait pas tant thuillies bien sache le je
pense qu'anthony revient des états unis
n'aura pas tant pour son harmonie
revient ou ira en asie soit en revient
soit envie d'y aller un petit va c'est
[Musique]
parce que culture nippone à fond et
parce que dans le dessin d'une manière
ou d'une autre
pas forcément pour faire des planches de
bd peut être dans les jaquettes de
vidéos spaihts dans le stylisme dans le
graphisme dans un truc comme ça
du coup c'est quoi exactement six
stylistes manquait que je pense que ce
qui agace au plus haut point obtenu
c'est je vais développer le non respect
des process les gens qui sont pas leurs
dans quelque chose doit être fait d'une
telle manière qu'ils aient pas fait
alors que ça devrait être fait comme ça
tout ce genre de l'hiver mais je pense
vraiment que ça te gonfle alors que
harmony je pense que l ce qu'il agace
skis la gonfle vraiment c'est quand
c'est déloyal voilà manque de loyauté
mensonge dénigrer gratuitement ou
d'émigrer pour obtenir quelque chose je
dois je vous regarde pas quand je dis
pour pas interpréter ce que le premier
jeu tout comme ça donc ça fait partie de
ton top truck et qu'est ce que je peux
avoir 800 chaude un signe astro pas
preuve nom est peu capricorne oui oui ok
j'ai un point je me dirai plus de poids
j'ai fait la rencontre de tennis et plus
dire j'ai même pas trouvé dans son
métier n'est pas dit qu'on est qu'il est
ce que tu veux un indice de donner un
oui d'accord il aurait pas de points je
peux donner un indice sur tandja
j'utilise maintenant à [ __ ] posté au
poteau c'est ça le contrôle c'est ça
ouais c'est sûr et dans le truc que tu
aimes contact avec la nature
apaisement animaux etc ayé c'est bon
teint samat ou déverrouiller pour le
coup
[Musique]
mon gars ont fait semblant de personnes
parce que la caméra elle tourne ok mais
on n'a pas prévu de cech
merci marshall je t'en prie ville ceux
qui regardent à waimes met your mother
dites moi dans les commentaires si vous
trouvez pas que c'est un peu marshall
tellement pas bon quoi qu'il en soit moi
ou à 17 ans merci du coup tu accèdes
oméga défi donc en fait on a commandé
six cloches oui et on leur a demandé
quels étaient leurs plats préférés qui
on vient de les commander en livraison à
tous les hommes et la whey et ça vient
d'arriver
du coup on va le mettre sur la table
ouais il faut que tu pourra revenir des
adversaires tu pourra regarder sous la
cloche et leur dire tu viens la thune ok
d'accord
bon courage ok c'est quoi cette araignée
4 parce que deux jeux vous est grillé
j'étais sûr que vous avez une phobie des
petites bêtes voilà c'est tout c'est ça
que j'ai quand en fait tout à l'heure à
rome j'arrivais au soutien j'ai un truc
sur vous mais j'ai hâte au tchèque
vous savez que je tiens je vais vous
dire un truc intéressant
cette vidéo n'est pas sponsorisé il n'y
a pas de partenaire ça veut dire que en
règle de tout ça parce qu'on veut faire
ce type de vidéos là quand tu vois le
prix des cloches le prix des plats le
prix de la location et si vous doutez
bien que c'est loin d'être gratuit qu'il
vidéos youtube ne peut pas
s'autofinancer
c'est pour ça que des fois il ya des
placements produits dans le bureau en
face calmes et j'ai parfois des
commentaires de hébert placement de
produit pour ça oui parce qu'en fait on
stocke aussi de l'argent pour faire ce
genre de vidéos c'est tout ce que
j'avais à dire merci beaucoup mais un
pouce en l'air bonne touati de la cloche
et ben vas-y moi je regarde les plats
c'est chaud ah ça j'aime bien aussi
je sais ce que c'est ça fait brûlant
d'accord ça c'est bien ça ça c'est mon
ami à moi
ainsi mes toiles a en fait j'ai dit avec
vous je pense que ces deux places et
vous deux il est bizarre c'est un
entrepreneur je te mettrai bien ici donc
dit si je me trompe dans les prénoms des
fouets j'aime être lentement si j'ai
qu'une erreur se rassurent au bout des
six j'ai plein d'erreurs on s'en fout de
ce moulin bien ah oui donc du coup par
des fautes à sa foi mais samedi les
moyens d un merde
marie samadet bien non mais marie c'est
sûr je couds
même question est maintenant bas par
élimination je te mets devant
du coup en fait c'est que si ça c'est
pour toi bon c'est à dire que j'ai mal
cerné certaines choses et si c'est pas
pour toi j'ai peur que ça fasse un effet
de domino effectivement de passe alors
maintenant moi c'était super mais moi
aussi
on verra un parti ce que ces vieux truc
de brigands là parce que tu assumes de
tromper en vidéo bah oui bien sûr ce
soir de la première fois alors là je
vous le dis j'ai par contre je suis à
l'aise avec le fait de me tromper mais
d'une force
est-ce que tu arrêtes à une personne
n'était sûr sûr sûr assurer une personne
dont je suis pas sûr du tout une
personne dont je suis sûr sûr sûr ce
serait ce sera mal à la poutine
cool nickel next g après deux mois un
plat pizza avec fromage à raclette
tartiflette laval yade qu'il l'avait ça
oui c'est un meuble a préféré aussi
c'est parfait je te voyais bien sûr la
fisam et spécialement sur celle ci ben
je pense qu'il vaut mieux sans mauvais
jeu de mots il vaut mieux compte soulève
parce que comme vous deux jeux vraiment
j'ai un doute sur le fait que ça
s'invente ici on m'a dit ça va me donner
un peu la fin une espèce de margarita au
chèvre
oui ça ça bah oui il peut le dire il y
avait quelqu'un d'autre qui avait un
plat similaires ou pas non puisque sinon
j'en aurais vu deux qui se ressemblent
ok ça marche ok c'est pas exactement ça
que tu m as les couilles j'ai 50 % de
bonnes réponses de sueur après là ça
peut faire un effet domino etc sachez
que si je me plante je m'en fous parce
que je suis déjà content d'avoir fait la
moitié ou j'ai une erreur où j'ai trois
erreurs parce qu'il ya trop peur si j'ai
deux heures et deux erreurs sais pas si
c'est possible
ah oui mais non je propose qu'on te
soulève harmonie paraissent ce qu'on
peut ouvrir sans mauvais jeu de mots je
sais même pas ce que c'est c'est quoi ça
comme cela qu'il s'agit de ramen oui je
sais pas ce que vous n'avez jamais mangé
c'est quoi d'accord ok ok donc je peux
avoir
il n'y a pas ce que je peux lui allait
changer de place encore fabien c'est ce
que j'avais proposée
moi j'ai envie de vous échanger un vieux
proverbe qui dit quand tu as un doute
c'est qu'il ya pas de doute on changeait
alors je change les assiettes
ensemble je suis bien sûr de moi sur le
dernier coup va en fait on soulèvera les
cloches à 10000 l'ied c'est la méthode
possible
non allez j'arrête j'annonce que
emmanuel même pas manger chaud ça frémit
sa famille jeanne ans qu'on est sur du
sushi c'est pas mal oui et donc il ya
qui tories pour toi liés que tu aurais
ri oui ça marche oui et bien je le
savais tu le départ j'ai pas eu de doute
je veux dire c'était très très clair
merci beaucoup merci à vous la table n'a
plus qu'à manger quoi c'est vraiment vos
plats donc sauf qu'il ya pas de tomates
de lipides voilà fabien je t'avais
premier un truc oui je t'avais dit que
si tu réussis c'est un grand défi oui tu
avais le droit un petit truc un petit
cadeau oui je les ai vus arriver dans la
cloche le pôle manger tout ça ce qui
intéressait que grâce à ça tout ça si
les plats préférés je fais vraiment
derrière et ce partout à cette terrible
ne fait jamais ça mais voilà merci j'ai
envie de pleurer je t'embrasse merci
beaucoup d'avoir regarder ses vidéos
merci alors attends je me refais les
images mentales dans l'ordre merci à
anthony merci à benoît mercier à harmony
merci à marie merci à emmanuel et merci
à elisa d'avoir participé à cette vidéo
merci beaucoup à pierre et à fanny
d'avoir organiser tout ça dans mon dos
van cloche très peu services achetés 160
euros je les fais à moitié prix voilà
n'hésitez pas dans les commentaires vous
passez votre annonce aussi si vous
voulez n'hésitez pas également à me dire
ce que vous avez pensé dans les
commentaires je trouve que moi
personnellement je trouve que j'ai pas
donné énormément de choses à donner pas
mal quand même pas énorme il ya dites
moi si vous aussi vous avez d'autres
hypothèses et où vous essayez d'aller
voir dans les commentaires si vous
pouvez répondre un peu tout ça peut être
cool
qu'est ce que je vais vous dire d'autre
que mon spectacle continue dans les
villes qui sont affichées ici ici ici
ici ici ici ça c'est mon instagram
mais un petit peu élastique moi je vous
dis à très bientôt un très fort et je
n'ai pas hâte de finir cette vidéo parce
que je suis quelqu'un d'ambitieux